hey youtubers is charlie so huge news
Stephen Amell just announced that he and
Stardust are going to have a rematch on
arrow season 5 I mean I'm even wearing
my Stardust vml t-shirt everybody's
always like what's this t-shirt this is
from SummerSlam last year when they
fought each other
we have an announcement we have a new
guest star on arrow
so what's going on Stephen Amell just
announced that Stardust will be coming
on for one episode it's episode 34
season 5 it'll be kind of like a rematch
for their Stardust vml from last year if
you guys missed it between season 3 and
4 Stephen Amell went on SummerSlam like
right after Comic Con before season 4
started and up to that moment he and
Stardust had been teasing this rivalry
like he went and watched a match to
himself start us got all up in his face
so they tease this big rivalry than they
paid it off during SummerSlam Stephen
Amell ended up winning that match they
were really nice I mean most of those
fights are choreographed so behind the
scenes they usually have an idea for
who's going to win the fight like they
have a general plan for how the fight is
going to go so naturally people are like
when are you gonna do this again it was
so much fun watching him get the [ __ ]
kicked out of him and him jumping off
the ropes that was actually a pretty
badass finishing move and he actually he
even got approval from Warner Brothers
to wear his arrow costume he's not
allowed to wear that in public unless he
gets permission from Warner Brothers
just because it's IP but Stephen Amell
like she said something were like funny
he's like I didn't really explain
exactly what was going to be going on to
the people at Warner Brothers so for
insurance purposes it's usually really
hard to let actors do stuff like that
usually studios are like no way we're
not gonna let you almost kill yourself
you're our most precious asset you're
the lead at one of our TV shows if you
go down how are we going to make the TV
show so it all ended up being pretty
cool but then what happened is the
Stardust left the WWE so it's like how
they gonna get into a fight unless they
go to a bar together and have too much
to drink so the easy answer is Stephen
Amell goes on his TV show now he comes
on Stephen amell's TV show but they
didn't really say anything about the
character he's gonna be playing he could
be like a heckler while mayor queen is
trying to give a speech and he just
dives off the podium to stop them from
yelling the other thing we don't know is
if Oliver Queen is going to be fighting
him as the arrow or as mayor Queen like
will it happen during the day is it
going to happen at night with his arrow
costume on so either way Stardust is
going to be a comic book character or
he's going to be some Rando dude that
Oliver just has to take out the only
thing I think we can count on is that
there will be a fight they will totally
throw down so because Stephen Amell was
able to win that SummerSlam match I
think that they'll give start us some
really good shots on Oliver
he's just the latest in the grand
tradition of crazy wrestlers coming onto
TV shows and being crazy characters you
probably remember edge from the flash
season 2 he played both the earth one
and earth two versions of atom smasher
so what will be really cool is because
arrow is doing like the proliferation of
vigilantes in Star City you have to
remember after three years of people
trying to destroy the city that
everybody that's left it still willing
to live inside Star City is probably
batshit crazy so of course they're all
going to turn into vigilantes and start
going crazy I'm gonna clean up my city
but up inside all their heads it's going
to be complete crazy talents so
obviously Oliver's gonna be like okay I
understand you want to make the city
better but you can't kill anybody so
just chill out bro so there's basically
going to be like a bunch of Omar's just
like wandering around Star City going
crazy so hopefully Stardust will be able
to be one of those people you know like
somebody who wants to make his city
better but it's just totally crazy so he
goes way over the line and Oliver has to
stop him that's basically what's going
to be happening with the main characters
there's two big new main characters that
they brought onto the show that I've
talked about in previous episodes
they're kind of like Punisher types
people who are vigilantes just like the
arrow was in season one who killed
people so now part of the drama is that
Oliver's on the other side of this
equation you know he used to be the guy
who was killing people trying to make a
city better now because he's the mayor
he's like the man on the hill so he's
got to figure out how he's going to deal
with all these people who are killing
bad guys because taking down bad guys
really awesome killing people not so
awesome and Stephen Amell has been
teasing like one of the things that he's
most excited for in season five is kill
shots meaning that there will be a lot
of bodies dropping so I'm expecting when
they drop the comic con trailer we will
see a whole bunch of bodies dropping
like how do you tell everybody that
watches the show or used to watch the
show that a bunch of vigilantes are
going to be killing people in season 5
will you put some of that in the trailer
you just have a bunch of awesome
gratuitous kill shots in there so let me
know you know Stardust coming on arrow
what do you want his character to do I
feel like it would be a really good
opportunity for someone to just heckle
the [ __ ] out of Mayor Queen while he's
trying to give a speech and then later
that night that same heckler does
something to break the law and Oliver
gets to take him down and beat the [ __ ]
out of him
so speaking of beating the [ __ ] out of
stuff I'm going to be doing a berserk
video later tonight if you've never
watched that anime it is super hardcore
it's streaming on crunchyroll right now
so be sure to watch berserk episode 1 on
crunchyroll that video will post a
little bit later I'll explain what's
going on because if you haven't watched
anime before or you haven't watched
berserk it's super hardcore so trigger
warning it is crazy but it's going to be
a really awesome summer anime and it's
going to be streaming each week there
will be a new episode each week so why
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to learn all about the
villain for flash season 3 a couple
theories about who tom felton plank and
you can click here for my review and the
easter eggs from the batman v superman
ultimate edition thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you